[Music]
pastor mark the question is is it true
that god already elected who will be
saved and who will not be saved great
question ephesians 1 verse 4 says
according has he has chosen us in him
before the foundation of the world that
we should be holy and without blame
before him in love having predestined us
unto the adoption of children by jesus
christ to himself according to the good
pleasure of his will to the praise of
the glory of his grace where he had made
us accepted in the beloved the truth of
the matter is that every one of us were
chosen by god
every single one of us were predestined
by god to be saved it's our choice
whether we accept god's choosing and we
accept the pre-designed plan that god
has for us so did god predestine us
before the beginning of the world to be
yes he did every single person born
there's a pre-designed plan that god has
for that life for them to know him to
serve him and to love him but we are not
locked into that pre-designed plan we're
not bound to that pre-designed plan we
have to choose to follow christ and he
but he has elected every one of us to be
saved he's pre-designed a plan for every
one of us every one of us are accepted
in the beloved when christ died he died
for the whole human race
john says that jesus is the propitiation
for our sins that's the ransom for our
sins propitiation just another word for
that and not for ours only but for the
sins of the whole world so christ died
and reconciled the world unto himself
we have to choose whether we accept what
christ has done and whether we respond
to what he's done he has a pre-designed
plan for your life as he does for every
human being and he'll do everything he
can to save you all right pastor mark
thank you for that answer hey everybody
matt gray here media director for
hopeless365 don't go yet make sure that
you subscribe and click the bell so you
get notified of the next video in this
series and i think you should check out
these other videos over there i think
you'll like those as well see ya